see you've all been away all summer you
have plenty of
wow really noisy in here pleased to
welcome new and returning students
faculty and staff to the opening lecture
of our fall 2010 lecture series
tonight's lecturers Bridget chim arrow
siren and visiting professor and
architecture professor shim is no
stranger to Yale she was the bishop for
visiting professor in 2001 in fall 2005
she returned a siren and visiting
professor and in spring 2008 as
Davenport visiting professor Bridget
shimmers principal in the Toronto firm
shim Sutcliff founded in nineteen ninety
four a firm that is internationally
admired for its thoroughly conceived
meticulously crafted work and I there
are some seats down here Peter for the
grown-ups for the late grown-ups well
time is slower and this real time in
modernist time
as I was saying for internationally
known for that consumer ticularly
conceived crafted work the work of shem
center is the product of a deep
appreciation and understanding of the
nature of building sites of functional
program and especially of natural and
man-made materials at a time when many
architects de-emphasize issues of
materiality and craft not to mention
program and site in favor of what of
what they presume to be conceptual
aspects of architecture professor Sims
work is all the more important to the
health of the profession a graduate of
the University of Waterloo in Canada she
has been a member of the faculty of the
university of toronto since 1988 and has
taught as visiting professor at the
occult polytechnique fédérale de
Lausanne in Switzerland and at Harvard's
Graduate School of Design Bridget shim
and her partner Howard southcliffe have
represented Canadian design in
international exhibitions and they're
built work has been published widely in
North and South America Europe and Asia
professor shim currently serves on the
board of Bill Toronto Waterfront
Toronto's design review committee the
University of Toronto's design review
committee and the editorial board of
praxis journal of building and writing
in 2007 she served on the Agra con r
katek chur award master jury after the
lecture please join professor shim for a
reception at the opening of the
exhibition the structure of light
Richard Kelly and the illumination of
modern architecture designed by Dean
Sakamoto of our faculty and curated by
deitrick Norman of Brown University who
was Vincent Scully professor in our
school from two
thousand seven to two thousand nine
professor Newman is or should be in the
audience tonight I haven't seen him but
there is he's there and we'll be pleased
to meet with you and to meet you at the
reception after the lecture now let us
welcome bridge Bridget Shem arrow siren
and visiting professor to the podium as
she delivers the lecture remapping my
world Bridget
hello can you hear me at the back is it
good first of all Thank You Dean Stern
for your introduction and your
invitation to come back to Yale it's
always a pleasure to be here and I guess
over the kind of four visits that I've
had here close to a decade I've really
seen this amazing reinvigoration of an
already stellar architecture school and
I think that it's the strengthening and
deepening of its faculty the ph.d
program the renovation of this landmark
building is really a kind of metaphor of
transformation and I think a lot of the
credit is due to its wonderful
leadership so I think it's just as an
outsider to kind of see that from time
to time I just see the kind of just the
strengths emerging so it's really just a
pleasure to be here for my partner
Howard Sutcliffe who isn't here and
myself architecture refuses together
both poetic ideas inert materials
physical sight and social conditions
architecture trades on its ability to
touch and shape people's lives in
profound and meaningful ways around the
world no matter where it is being
practiced architecture is a complex
discipline I think that for us as a
counterpoint to a kind of growing
sameness or place lessness I both Howard
and I feel we need to support and
celebrate ways of building community
that emerges from a deep understanding
of local cultures and building
traditions while simultaneously
addressing the layered complexities of
our modern world the discipline of
architecture needs to nurture
alternative models of practice that link
and support committed designers to work
directly with local communities to
engage in projects that have the
capacity to build and transform those
communities these buildings reflect the
communitys aspirations and they need to
be exemplary architecture of the highest
design
quality I think that that's essential
perhaps that Yale's architecture school
this is not a new idea that your
school's first year building project has
been the cornerstone of your program for
over 40 years building buildings and
serving community are a kind of joint
objective of that program and I think
it's really one of the distinguishing
aspects of the school and needs to keep
going and to be fostered the title of my
talk is remapping my world and in 2007
while serving on the yoga conjury I
wrote in an essay after the jury
experience that it sort of recalibrated
my senses and that i felt i needed to
remap my world that it had kind of
changed my perception of you know the
geography that i operated in and so
during this talk what i wanted to do is
remap my own work and really sort of
reflect upon this question of mapping as
a way of recontextualizing what where we
are what we do and why we do it so in
Canada we're really part of a small part
of what is a big country and I wanted to
use in the talk itself the lens of the
Canadian Shield the Great Lakes the
urban back alleys of Toronto and the
verdant ravine system to really frame or
kind of understand the work in a
different way I would say our work Jim
suck less work is very local unlike many
of my colleagues in other parts of
Canada we really created a practice
where we actually don't get on an
airplane to go to a project site unless
we can help it and that by building
local you know a place through its
geomorphology its climate its cultural
history and in a way this allows us the
luxury of being able to more accurately
calibrate the provocation of intensity
between the wild and unpredictable
forces of nature and the control
processes of contemporary fabrication by
building loko we can perhaps become a
more relevant part
of a broader global conversation so the
kind of idea that local isn't a
pejorative but actually a way of
actually maybe making a different kind
of contribution so the first map I have
sorry Oh is on I'm sorry and it's a kind
of situating math because it's actually
a map of the British Commonwealth and
everything that's pink is actually the
Commonwealth and in America it may not
be as relevant or as pertinent but I was
actually born in Kingston Jamaica
somewhere in the Caribbean and my
husband Howard was born in the UK so I
think of us as products of the
Commonwealth and then we both live in
Toronto which is this extremely
multicultural City so in a way being
from somewhere else makes us a citizen
of Toronto and I think that this post
colonial condition has really
interesting ramifications at this point
of the 21st century because it talks
about an inherent complexity and a
layered condition so you think about a
writer like Michael on da che I don't
know people know his work but he was
born in Sri Lanka educated in Britain
and lives in Toronto you wrote a seminal
book called in the skin of the lion
where he uses two extraordinary pieces
of public infrastructure the RC Harris
water filtration plant and the blur
viaduct to situate the building of the
city as a metaphor so the idea that an
immigrant with this kind of layered
background maybe more perceptive about
Toronto than maybe people that have
lived there their whole lives the kind
of maybe other frame for us is the
Canadian Shield and if you think of this
sort of the dots here from a kind of
textbook map the shield is described as
a stone necklace around Hudson's Bay a
post-glacial landscape very scarcely
populated thousands of lakes and
containing in effect much of the boreal
forests of Canada the view on the right
is a view from the group of seven a
group of Canadian painters who would go
out into the
landscape with little pieces of masonite
actually do their sort of early sketches
with the wind blowing and in their face
and then go back to their studios and
paint these larger canvases but they
were the first group to not try to turn
the Canadian landscape into a European
one but to depict depict the rawness and
the kind of the sort of wildness of that
landscape and so in this map I'm showing
in effect the range of projects that
we've done in the shield and when we say
shield given its scale we are really at
the bottom end of the shield so we're
sort of like we're at the point where
the shield touches the kind of more
genteel agrarian landscape this project
is a dining hall for a camp for
inner-city kids but if someone told you
this was in Finland you probably would
believe them so this kind of similarity
of the geomorphological structure the
trees is very similar to that kind of
circumpolar belt the project is a very
low budget project uses off-the-shelf
materials greenhouse glazing as you can
see from this element here that is used
for industrial production greenhouses to
provide ventilation as well as light
using local materials a kind of
articulation of wall and roof and the
separation of the two to really create a
place for dining three meals a day using
very elemental pieces like two by fours
which are this kind of whole element
here that really acts more is a light
monitor it's not being used structurally
a hybrid structural system combining
glulam frames and steel members to
really create a kind of hybrid trust our
engineers or we drive our engineers
crazy because we love using combinations
of steel and wood together they expand
and contract differently they can't be
done in the computer so we sort of
really give them a hard time and they
have to work hard for their fees with
the summer camp this kind of condition
of seasonality and the ability to kind
of both use these
extended elements to create intimate
spaces but also they can close the
entire building down within an hour so
this kind of understanding of the
seasons and summer and winter is very
important in our climatic zone so here
you get these intimate spaces that act
as the briefs ole's but also provide the
kind of winter shut down really quickly
the summer porches that actually extend
the building program which i think is
really important given the kind of
seasonal dimension of these buildings
and the way that it responds to the
landscape using gained off-the-shelf
barn roofing and greenhouse glazing
combined with local cedar to really
become part of its landscape and yet be
distinct from it at the same time a
project we did at the same time a
boathouse and where this kind of in the
studio that I'm doing is this kind of
zone of shoreline wetland water and I'm
really interested in things like the
supports we use these heavy timber cribs
and fill them with boulders so the kind
of idea of the underwater infrastructure
the relationship between above and below
the water line are things that interest
us and fascinate us studies of kind of
this question of under and above so the
water line would actually be about here
with things below and above it and
things that are normally hidden get
revealed so we're combining heavy
Timbers with Douglas fir and using wood
in a variety of ways so trying to
understand the kind of tradition of wood
construction and tapping into the kind
of extremes of both a heavy timber
underwater infrastructure so the
underwater being pulled above and almost
a boat building craft tradition in them
being used simultaneously in the same
project so here we're taking a material
like the heavy Timbers which are
recycled Timbers from a demolished
building and using them in a way
that is more plastic where you have your
reading layers and corners and a kind of
level of plasticity that normally
doesn't come with the kind of heavy
timber material and I gained this kind
of love of the hybrid so we're using
wood and steel in kind of different ways
and combining and recombining them to
create new conditions and again this
kind of places that are normally dark
have light to them and kind of always
trying to play with the kind of
vernacular and understand it and yet
rethink it at the same time indoor
spaces that really outdoor spaces indoor
spaces that feel more like outdoor
spaces spaces that really are about
viewing the landscape or changing your
relationship to it the kind of question
of these traditions and how they're
reinvented so a ceiling that feels like
the underside of a boat and the kind of
use of different scales of material to
really play with your perceptions of
these things at the same time and so
we're kind of always driving our
contractors crazy and the kind of idea
about how it understands and situates
itself in the landscape another project
again on the shield a small lake in an
area called Halliburton no relationship
to the other companies this is before
all that stuff and the idea that it's
almost like a treehouse in the kind of
forest and again here is the whole
series of sections or something that's
linear has these very varied spatial
conditions because of the manipulation
so we're kind of taking this long skinny
thing and slicing it through these
sections in a variety of ways probably
the most important section is this one
where there's a double height space and
that the whole project revolves around
so it's a double height outdoor space
with indoor spaces around it
a model giving you a sense of that in
the way that it and you create these
conditions where you're inside looking
outside looking inside a game and a very
simple plan I would say our plans almost
appear kind of very understated and
simple because our interest is really in
the section and so we try to achieve a
level of simplicity in the plan so that
we can actually be really exploratory in
the sectional and spatial qualities so
here you have a house where you have the
kind of structural wall back here and
then you get cantilever upon cantilever
so you get these long overhangs where
the soffit becomes a whole other kind of
elevation to the building and then
inside this kind of idea of these
penetrations into the landscape these
varied volumes so this become quite high
volumes within a linear experience and
then these folded spaces that where
you're sort of folding them and you're
inside looking out looking in a game and
again a very simple material palette
poured-in-place concrete Douglas fir so
really reducing the palette and then
here you can see in the landscape these
kind of this double height space that
becomes in effect the pivotal experience
that's outside and then the folding of
these interior spaces around it and the
way that it frames views of the
landscape this is in winter looking out
to the lake and this kind of issue of
the shoreline actually being part of the
experience and then from the kind of
woods where you're actually again seeing
it as almost a kind of pavilion in the
forest and these kind of layers of
extension beyond and then a very recent
project where it was part of a kind of
grouping of log buildings
done in a kind of more traditional log
way and wanting a new building to be
part of this ensemble so here we are
looking at a kind of stacked log wall a
kind of reflecting pool a skylight and
really playing with this kind of idea of
wood in a different way so here you're
seeing the relationship of the
reflecting pool and the kind of entrance
the kind of end of the building where it
gains shift scale from almost being
miniature to being heroic so on the
right hand side you can see the lake and
the kind of forest on the left and then
this kind of reflecting pool where you
come from the lower level and you come
up the view of the lake from the inside
and the view at night where you get this
kind of change in condition is a
sandblasted glass wall behind the log so
the day to night condition transforms in
the house hopefully appears to levitate
the next kind of frame for me and the
kind of mapping is the Great Lakes and
it is the largest body of fresh water in
the world so the five Great Lakes if you
remember your geography lessons twenty
percent of the Earth's freshwater
incredible and the kind of watershed of
the Great Lakes impacts much of North
America of the central portion of the
continent in this kind of textbook view
you can actually see Niagara Falls which
is here so you can see that this body of
water is actually the force that drops
over niagara falls on a kind of every
second and the depth of Lake Superior is
always astounding to me the kind of it's
almost like a mountain range underwater
so this kind of a game it's love of
underwater above water condition so in a
way we've done a few projects one in the
Thousand Islands
and 2 on Georgian Bay that I'll share
with you they often refer to the Great
Lakes as the third coast so if you
unravel the shoreline it would be like
the Pacific or the Atlantic coast of the
continent so this is a project in the
Thousand Islands you have to take a
ferry to get there and it's called the
island house both literally it's on an
island but also metaphorically the kind
of idea of the island has a green roof a
kind of clover meadow and the project
begins because this is an agrarian
landscape it's a dairy farming island
and many of the dairy farms are being
bought up and turned into suburban
houses and this kind of it begins with a
kind of love of this pastoral landscape
and wanting to find a way to kind of
retain it while changing the use and so
we planted a kind of five acre clover
meadow as part of the kind of idea of
the landscape and a local farmer comes
cuts it down and has this agricultural
cycle even though it is no longer kind
of a dairy farming a piece of land and
the section again is always important to
us and the idea that you actually come
into the project and there's a
reflecting pool that's actually as large
as a house and the idea that the water
garden allows you to feel close to the
water even though all the regulations
and the authorities prevent you from
being close to the waters the irony is
anyone with waterfront has to be 66 or
100 feet back from the water line
because of all the shoreline issues so
here you can see the reflecting pool
which is close to the kind of size of
the habitable interior space and so when
you enter you actually don't see the
water you actually see the upper portion
of a kind of almost a lantern that we've
created out of fiberglass and then you
descend down and it's only as you enter
that you the pool unravels and kind of
becomes evident and they wanted a
screened-in porch so we turned the whole
living room into a cubic volume that
with big sliding doors to create
kind of porch and then views of this
amazing water garden with the biggest
bullfrogs you've ever seen and this kind
of idea that the water landscape is as
important as the kind of other grasses
and landscape beyond and then here in
the distance you can see the st.
Lawrence River so here's this kind of
cubic volume they're kind of modernist
version of a screened-in porch and then
here you can see the clover meadow late
in the season where the clover goes dry
the farmer cuts it down and then they
use all the grasses for the local cows
and then really recently we added a
studio in a lap pool to this same
complex so you can see one building from
the other and the lap pool kind of
extends this water element and stretches
it out into the landscape the studio is
for art from the desk you're looking
back to the house itself in the distance
and here you can see the kind of new
studio and the existing house and
they're kind of relationship and a kind
of reading of both the kind of site and
the context our client loves 60s modern
sculpture and has been collecting pieces
to be part of this landscape for several
years and a very kind of small and very
low budget project that we did which is
in an old apple orchard a 35 year old
apple orchard a plywood box with a stone
extension and you can see the kind of
triangular plywood tower a stair
wrapping around a local stone wall and a
kind of living and kitchen area the
plywood is both inside and outside so
again we're always pulling things in and
out and trying to
create that ambiguity of what is in and
out gain trying to situate you so this
low horizontal building literally
becomes part of the orchard so you
actually feel like you're in the orchard
when you're looking out your kitchen
window and this kind of sense of this
ensemble this kind of agrarian kind of
landscape and these kind of groupings of
buildings in them this is actually a
painting by a Canadian painter named
Patterson Ewan and we actually designed
a studio for him several years before he
died and he did a whole body of work in
it before he passed away and he was
really an inspiration for us because he
was very interested in climate and
weather and depicting in effect the kind
of these climatic conditions and he used
plywood he was called the router guy so
he is plywood and then painted the
plywood with alkaline dies and if you
went to Frank Gehry's new art gallery of
ontario you would see a whole body of
his work that is well really well
displayed there this project is a kind
of wood intent it's a kind of a prefab
experiment in Georgian Bay so here's
this early sketch one of the issues is
that we had to take every material had
to be transported like the dining hall
for the camp from the city onto a truck
from the truck to the marina from the
marina on to a bar from the barge onto
the site from the site to the actual
building location so this question of
the kind of handling of materials and
the lightness of them was actually a
criteria that we had to really think
about very carefully a sketch were the
kind of ideas it feels like a porch that
it doesn't really feel like a habitable
building but more like a shelter and
more like a wooden tint and here's a
kind of study model trying to understand
the light condition structure and the
relationship between them and again
because of this kind of imperative of
the delivery and the weight of things
and transportation we actually imagined
thinking about it as a prefab and not in
a kind of dwell like prefab but actually
a series of prefabricated component
pieces done in a controlled environment
assembled and then shipped up to the
site so it allowed us a kind of way of
working with skilled carpenters in a
controlled environment very little
wastage and then a kind of sight
assembly but of preassembled pieces and
here's a kind of drawing where the kind
of questions of how you hit the Canadian
Shield and the ways that you actually
connect to it I think we're very
important to us typically they're heavy
concrete footings and we wanted
something that was actually very light
and felt that it was not really scarring
this ancient rock we also built a full
prototype of one Bay of the project and
then we had our structural engineers
come and sign off on it so we kind of do
that the we reverse engineered it we did
what we think thought would work and
then we got them to look at it they
added a couple things and then said it
was okay so and then this is how they
brought all these pieces onto the site
so it looks a bit like Tom Sawyer and
Huckleberry Finn but it's kind of a way
of actually bringing all these pieces
onto the site there are issues of the
seasonality the lack of skilled labor
the kind of remoteness of the location
that really required a different way of
thinking and then a kind of in process
so these are not finished photographs
but they give you a sense of a Courtin
roof and a kind of again a different
kind of greenhouse glazing and custom
sliders that pull back and transform it
into a porch in a sense of this kind of
amazing landscape that is part of the
foreground this group of seven landscape
and again these kind of component pieces
frame views of the forest relative to
open views of the bigger landscape of
the bay and again these kind of ways
that you read this layered landscape
so the next area of kind of mapping is
the Golden Horseshoe and so Niagara
Falls is situated right about here this
is the Niagara Gorge niagara-on-the-lake
is here Buffalo is back here and Toronto
is here in this area is the economic
engine of Canada it's the largest
population Richard Florida has invented
all kinds of names for it that are kind
of turning it into a megalopolis from
Oshawa for him all the way to Rochester
is this kind of a whole new kind of mega
city and in Toronto were situated really
in my view more like this on the north
shore of Lake Ontario so while we're
part of this megalopolis you really see
yourself at the edge of one of the Great
Lakes this is a view of Toronto and when
I was in high school we were asked to do
an urban geography project I ended up
talking to people in the planning
department and they thought my project
was actually really interesting but they
said you know you should talk to this
person named Jane Jacobs and I actually
didn't know who she was at the time and
I phoned they gave me her phone number
and I called her I told her what my
project was and she said well it sounds
interesting but I think you should limit
it and you should know your own backyard
so she her so I had this big project in
mind and her idea was don't make it so
big make it smaller and what you and by
making it smaller you actually really
know everything that you research and
that if it was in your own backyard it
was better than doing something far away
and in the way it's something that sort
of then realized how important she was
and what I kind of huge figure she was
and I kind of took me a while but I got
it and so I just want to share some
mapping I've done with my students at
the University of Toronto we've been
looking at laneways in the city this is
a view by a photographer named Arthur
Gausman from the late 1800s
documented all of Toronto's laneways
they're all in the archives they're
quite amazing talking about the
character of the city my students did
projects looking at laneways but before
that we actually started to map them and
in a way like the site that I'm doing
for my studio I'm interested in these
sight unseen these things that are right
under our nose but a little bit
invisible and trying to understand them
and understand what their qualities are
and not to eradicate them but to
actually give them a frame or a fuller
understanding in our society so I'm not
had my students look at locked division
built form and to actually start to
understand this emerging laneway system
in the city the same time we went to the
City of Toronto and said do you know how
many laneways there are in the city and
the head of Public Works said I don't
know so here so in the whole city of
toronto they're about 280 kilometers of
laneways but in the urban core which is
the study area they're about a hundred
and twenty kilometers and what you're
seeing only the laneways being drawn
then with my students we actually looked
at the types of laneways and we started
to give them names so we have Eileen Zed
lanes t lanes that they actually start
to have frequencies in different areas
of the city so in certain areas because
of a lot division and the way the
developers sort of broke up the land
there longer uninterruptedly ins where
in other parts they're shorter lanes
because a gain of the relationship of
railway lines and main streets and how
the lots were subdivided so not only
mapping type but frequency across the
city really gave us a kind of new
collaging a kind of remapping of the
system again that's right under our nose
and a kind of understanding of actually
making something invisible more apparent
I wouldn't say more visible but actually
reading it in a way that allows you to
understand the potentials and the
possibilities of this system itself so I
think in a way the kind of question of
mapping is something that I'm interested
in
many different scales at the kind of
scale of the city and then at the scale
of our own work very early project back
alley in Toronto and again you can see
it being hemmed in and only accessible
by kind of small laneways so in terms of
scale we're looking at 17 feet 45 feet
for the built form and a hundred and six
for the actual lot itself and if
situated within the pickup trucks in the
kind of existing condition so not trying
to change its context but more insert
something surgically into an existing
context and again this kind of question
of the section and the manipulation of
the ground plane and this kind of
insight outside where where the line
stops you're not really sure this
question of these kind of small
landscapes that have an intensity to
them and this question of seasons of
summer and winter being equally
important so really thinking about our
project in the middle of a snowstorm as
well as in a kind of verdant summer day
in both being actually part of the
thinking and the interest and then the
question of light to kind of ongoing
question for all architects in all
places I think that our latitude is 44
we're at latitude 44 so it has
challenges in terms of a northern light
in this kind of question of how to
amplify the light through the winter is
really something that we are we continue
to explore so from inside looking out
and the next project is and we have
we're starting to get these pairs of
projects where we did something 10 years
ago and then we come back and do
something else on the same site for the
same client so this was a very low
budget house clad in plywood for a
client who as an architect never
practice became an archivist
and so here you have the kind of upper
level and then the lower level then we
were asked to design a studio right next
to the house that we had built so here
you actually see the house we did ten
years ago and then this fairly new
studio and so here you're actually kind
of having a dialogue or a conversation
with yourself so it was a kind of one
room it was wanting a great deal of
light but no direct light so we created
these light monitors these light coffers
a very skinny skylight of a variety of
depths of wall thickness that dealt with
indoor storage outdoor storage and lot
lines sort of a whole kind of complex
set of competing agendas really to
create in effect a space that's full of
light with very little apertures or
light coming into it the above is all in
birch and then white drywall down below
and part of it was a viewing for
historic architectural photographs and a
large collection of architectural
posters so the kind of idea of display
was actually very much part of the
design program and this is a kind of
complete experiment and we actually have
just finished a synagogue in Portland
Maine and we actually used a lot of the
kind of lessons that we learned from
this to help us develop a whole agenda
for light
so the next kind of map or kind of frame
that I'm going to use our Toronto's
ravines and so here you're seeing the
kind of an aerial of the city so the CN
tower would be here Mies van der OHS
tower is very close by the university's
right here so the whole central core is
located here the Toronto Islands the
waterfront and in a way there's a hidden
another hidden landscape which are a
series of river valleys that really
bracket and frame the downtown this is
called the Don River and this is the
Humber River and in a way Toronto
ravines were described by Larry Richards
the former dean of the architecture
school as Toronto being San Francisco
turned upside down so if you imagine
that kind of inversion of of topography
in a way the ravines are also really
interesting because many of the major
writers such as Margaret Atwood and
Michael's Robert fulford Morley Callahan
and Marie McDonald really situate much
of their work in the ravines themselves
so Robert fulford states that the
ravines are the chief characteristic of
the local terrain its topographical
signature they are both a tangible
they'll often hidden part of our
surroundings and a persistent force in
our civic imagination they are the
shared subconscious of the municipality
the places where much of the city's
literature is born and for us this has
been the site for many of our projects
so in a way all of these dots are kind
of different projects that we've done at
the edge of the ravine itself in 1954
there was a hurricane hazel and you
don't think of Toronto as being a
hurricane's owned it was one of those
flute conditions and many buildings in
the ravine people used to live in the
ravines themselves were destroyed and a
public agency called the Toronto ravine
Toronto regional conservation authority
was formed as a reaction to this
natural disaster and they're responsible
for maintaining the ravine as an open
space as opposed to private land it
becomes in effect this public zone so
here are a series of black-and-white
photographs by stephen evans a toronto
photographer the depict and effects some
of the qualities of the ravine is
sometimes up to a 20 metre differential
between the top and the bottom of the
ravine so if you go as a tourist to
Toronto you think of it as a flat City
so again this negative landscape is
doesn't appear in any tourist brochures
it's never considered a feature but if
you live there as a citizen it becomes
this huge amenity this bike paths where
you can cycle for miles without ever
hitting a stoplight so this kind of
slightly the need to discover it is
actually part of its strength and again
the kind of you here you can see the
ravine down below with a roadway and
then the subway continuing and then the
kind of urban fabric of the city so
again this kind of topography that kind
of creeps up on you because if you were
to navigate the city you might not even
be aware of it and he gained a few of
the ravine there's a cross-country skier
in the foreground and then the kind of
urban fabric beyond so very early
project a kind of small garden pavilion
but in a way the DNA of a lot of
continued explorations retaining walls a
kind of interest in materials and this
kind of intertwining of built form and
landscape for the same client on the
same site a recent pavilion using a kind
of prof'l it glass as a lantern this
kind of ambiguity of in and out
fireplaces that are inside and outside
and a kind of framing of this kind of
verdant ravine landscape so you're
looking at black locust
and walnut trees within the cut and
you're literally in the ravine in this
case and another project called the
weathering steel house where in effect
the house is clad in weathering steel
and it's a kind of material that we've
been interested in using because it
reacts to the kind of atmospheric
conditions so again these things these
atmospheric conditions that are normally
unseen are actually registered in
relation to the court in and so we've
started off with that first garden
pavilion quite a while ago using it
there's a big steel company in Hamilton
called stelco and we phone their
research departments and we really want
to use this material and they said under
no circumstances should you use it they
had all these lawsuits with corten steel
that had been improperly detailed and
they had rusted out and so it got us
really interested and so we asked them
for a list of every project that had
used corten steel and so we went to
visit all of them and we figured out
from looking at them how they didn't
detail it properly why it failed because
they didn't drain it properly or the
gauge was too thin oil can and so from
actually seeing these kind of failures
we actually developed a way of thinking
about how to put it together and so
we've learnt a lot about the materials
really bye-bye just building a kind of
experiential understanding of them so
this project is situated in a very
suburban neighborhood we were interested
in using the texture of the steel so
there's almost like a kind of bar relief
of these rods with the steel and then
again sculpting out parts of the front
yard so we love digging and scraping and
shifting grade and altering your vantage
point entering and we like long slot
spaces as well as sort of
and then again a kind of water landscape
with the ravine edge beyond this is that
same view from the outside looking in
and then sort of these hovering pieces
where they're sort of cubic volume so
this is actually a skylight that brings
light down into the stairwell and then
views from the ravine edge looking back
in winter and from the inside looking
out again in winter so the project we
didn't realize this until it was built
actually lines up with the CN tower so
you can actually see it in the winter
and again this kind of layering of the
steel and the wood and these kind of
cutting away and the plasticity that
were interested in so in terms of the
ravine this project is called the
integral house and and for us it's at
the time that it was built it was for us
a really large project and and we really
thought of this as an experimental and
speculative project it really comes out
of a conviction and a belief that
architectural ideas and materials are
inextricably intertwined another way to
put it is that architecture is a
physical substance and in a way embedded
in its conceptualization is the
imperative to determine its materials as
part of the conceptual act the project
uses computer and manufactured processes
to realize its architectural vision so
flat and rotational laser cutting water
jet cutting casting 3d print outs
bending punching we kind of used
everything we could and had lots of fun
at the same time to kind of realize a
level of craft and the project we're
really fortunate our client is a
mathematician focused on calculus and as
well a concert violinist so
curves were part of the program it's he
said it had to have complex curving
volumes as well as a concert space a
performance phase for up to 150 people
so it had this kind of both private
program it's a house but a very public
program embedded in it so that kind of
oscillation that ambiguity was really
interesting for us ken Frampton called
this the endless house referring to the
seemingly endless yet fluid volumes of
space both inside and out so what I want
to do is share with you with this
project not only the project but also
the process because I think it gives you
a sense of the range of explorations
that and the types of models and things
we do in the studio so early study
models made of cardboard and wood and
tracing paper that really look at the
kind of volume so this is from the
street where you're looking really at a
two-story house because it's hugging the
edge of the ravine on the other side
it's actually five stories so you get
this sectional difference between the
kind of urban side and then this Wilder
ravine side and so part of the idea was
that you felt as if you entered the
ravine while never having to go outside
study models in wood acoustics were
really important to this kind of program
and our client said he didn't want to
bring in acousticians too early because
they would tell him that it should look
like a shoe box and so what we did is we
develop the architecture to a certain
point and then we had acousticians come
and we asked them two questions a do you
think it's going to work and be how can
we make it better and so they actually
gave us some suggestions that helped us
we listened and we modified sort of more
minor aspects of it to amplify the sound
but it wasn't driven by acoustics as the
primary driver of the project early
studies of a series of more denser what
we call wooden fins up here and then
kind of opening up to the ravine so it's
almost like a wooden curtain that opens
up and studying in effect the
relationship
of the denser and less dense aspects so
it's basically a custom curtain wall
that we developed by using prototypes
working with glass engineers to create a
kind of new system we use computers this
is a drawing of every single fin at what
we call the 400 level at the denser
level so you're kind of were you in a
way we would share these drawings with
the fabricators back and forth back and
forth everyone that bid on the fins had
to produce a fin so that they that
became their kind of submission to
determine whether they would get the
project sorry and we developed you know
sort of it's almost like fitting out
dresses so everyone is numbered and they
fit different parts of the fins so here
are some of those mock-ups where they
were each one is a difference the middle
by a different fabricator and then
sectional drawings detailed drawings of
these are the lower fins that were used
which are more standardized so you're
looking at the kind of ipe caps on the
exterior the glazing and then the wooden
fin where the frame is actually buried
in the actual window section so you
actually don't read a window frame all
you read is light and wood and here's a
full-size mock-up so again the glass
would actually fit right in here in
between and these fins are part of the
Interior and then this is part of the
exterior even we were able to design
even the door handle so you're looking
at a sequence from clay all the way
through to these which are 3d print outs
the 3d print outs were used as the kind
of mold for the casting so the kind of a
gain positive negative as you move
through it and the role of the computer
really as this amazing tool at every
stage of the process and then we were
really fortunate ed Burtynsky who's a
really well-known photographer you might
know his china books and his ship
wrecker series and his oil and water but
he's a friend and he photographed
demolition and the construction of the
building yes he had a camera fastened to
a tree covered up to look like a tree
house and it took a digital photographs
every 10 minutes for three years and he
was using it as an experiment because he
wanted to he was working with parts of
Shanghai depicting the transformation of
neighborhoods and this was a local
experiment to make sure the technology
worked and so we have this amazing
12-minute video of sort of multiple
seasons and but we have this kind of
amazing memory of the construction of
the project you can see the vertical
slope here of the kind of ravine edge in
the distance and the kind of scale of a
building in the ravine the issues of
construction that are really needed to
be holding back a kind of part of a
hillside and then drawings giving you a
sense of the section and if we were to
go to the bottom of the ravine we would
kind of be really off the page it's just
as part of the slope and then the
section where you start in at the upper
level so this is the street level and
you descend down to the performance
space which is one full floor below the
level of the street and then the plans
from the lowest level moving up there's
a large green roof here in ways that
this these spaces are almost an
extension of the existing contour lines
and then we developed with the computer
is a kind of complete cos steel template
that was used in the forum work so
you're kind of trying to create this
curvilinear thing in the middle of space
and this the precision of the the steel
template allowed a kind of level of
accuracy in the form work throughout and
then the site so here you're looking at
the brick works which is part of the
ravine system the CN Tower and the
building is located on the hillside here
so you're really in the kind of the Don
Valley ravine so this in the distance is
the blur viaduct that's part of Michael
and OJ's in the skin of the lion and
it's the kind of linking piece across
the valley that allowed for the
expansion of the city a view of it from
the kind of ravine side where you're
seeing this five-story building in the
ravine itself in winter from the street
side again a different scale all
together we're from the early model you
can see the kind of two story building
with hidden reflecting pools that only
appear when you get close to them a kind
of curving etch glass that's used here
with with LED lights behind it so at
night it has a kind of slightly liquid
quality to it the entrance where you're
kind of literally almost still part of
the city about to almost enter the
ravine and the kind of part of the
program again this you know concerts for
150 of my closest friends and this set
of sense of the layers of extension so
here you're literally along the contour
line so in a very Victorian city that's
really worried about side yards and no
fire penetrations it's this amazing
condition of leaving the city and
literally being in the ravine and it's
the only reason there was a pre-existing
house that grandfathered in this
condition that allowed it to be here in
the first place so again this kind of
serpentine path down to the main
performance space that almost extends
to the paths of the brickworks down
below and a kind of viewing back to the
urban part the kind of rectilinear
portion that is the entrance and the
kind of upper level more domestic spaces
like the dining areas actually become
balconies during the performance so it's
part of that duality of public and
private and then the main space itself
so you can see the denser wooden fins
here and then the more open fins down
below and in winter this kind of
changing light condition and again the
kind of interest in many of these
elements were computer fabricated so you
have up stands of limestone that are
curving in two directions and because of
the new technologies we could take
advantage of all of these things our
client loves glass and asked us to
collaborate with a glass artist and so
we worked with Mimi Gelman and she
developed an overall concept and we work
together to insert this secret blueglass
stare into the middle of the project so
it's this kind of series of blue glass
shingles with a skylight above it and
glass treads below it so the blue light
filters down vertically through the
project they're a series of cast bronze
clips that actually support the glass
shingles combined with stainless steel
cables and there are parts of the house
where you catch glimpses of it so you're
not in it but you see it from the
outside before you get into it and then
here you can see in the upper level not
only the curving blue glass but the
bronze clips and the stainless steel
cables
and then as you descend further again
you're kind of at the edge where the
stairs public stairs are never
rectilinear but always on the outboard
or inboard side so it feels like you're
traversing a natural feature and then at
the bottom is a kind of pool where
you're almost in the forest and Allah to
get hot there's a kind of 35 foot long
window that descends down into the
ground so when you're outside you're
really outside and then for the kind of
opening concert we designed a series of
music stands and in a way it's been a
really interesting learning experience
seeing everything from contemporary
dance performances to more classical
voice and piano too this is the C Mon
bulevar Orchestra a selection from the
larger C Mon bulevar group from Ecuador
playing in the space
and then a series of seasonal shots this
is spring summer fall and then winter so
i guess i wanted to conclude the overall
talk by moving maybe more outward and
reflecting on the word remapping which
was how i titled the talk and maybe
shift a bit to this kind of experience
of the auger conjury a jury we're
architects historians philosophers
artists are around the table having a
conversation and maybe to eavesdrop on
that conversation I just wanted to have
an excerpt from the jury report of 2007
in a way we talked about the idea of
scale not merely being a problem
internal to architectural knowledge or
practice but the scale of the
contemporary umma reveals the profound
differences in sites and localities
rural communities small towns industrial
cities private homes public institutions
that demand imagination and material
practical interventions scale is an
architectural intervention that responds
to site specificity while at the same
time creating or constructing a sense of
locality in that sense scale is an
ethical issue in a way the jury spent a
lot of time talking about sustainability
and we talked about sustainability pits
the grandiosity of our ambitions against
the available and appropriate scale of
Natural Resources how high should we
build how suitable our schemes for this
particular landscape climate need or
human interest sustainability as a scale
of aesthetic ethical and political
judgment creates an architecture that is
not just about building or buildings but
about creating an environment for
survival and well-being shared
expression in solidarity
so in a way this kind of question that
we keep asking ourselves about local and
issues local are really part of maybe a
larger conversation and what I just
wanted to do is share maybe some of the
issues that these projects that we
looked at really raised for the jury
this is a the Dutch embassy in Addis
Ababa and there was a huge discussion
about the intersection of architecture
and landscape architecture and sculpture
the kind of sustainability aspect of
these heavy load bearing concrete walls
and this kind of leaving a kind of mark
of how it's made this kind of cultural
mark at the same time this is a small
garden a park in a samir kassir park in
beirut designed but as a kind of urban
refuge the kind of idea of water and
public space actually being intertwined
together a project in Burkina Faso a
central market where this question of
sculptural spaces that are celebratory
related to public space where people
spend a lot of time so these are
actually self-supporting arches it's
sound and again they built one-to-one
prototypes they use these prototypes to
market to retailers to figure out their
material supplies to actually train
Mason's so again these kind of alternate
models of working of thinking about
markets not just as buildings but a
piece of public infrastructure I think
talk about the way that local issues
actually become maybe broader issues at
our in Singapore we're in a developer
driven culture the architects were able
to think and use new devices they
develop what was called a kind of
monsoon window where during a driving
rainstorm you could still get natural
ventilation in a tall tower and
developed a whole mechanism to allow
that to
happen within a much more slick curtain
wall system and so this kind of idea of
madera T as well as the vernacular and
this kind of questioning of both and the
reciprocity between both I think is
really interesting for architecture
students the kind of idea that you not
only could spend time in a place but but
create a project this is a the school in
rudrapur by Anna henninger where she in
effect spent a gap here in this village
just volunteering not quite knowing what
she wanted to be when she grew up and by
volunteering for a year developed a deep
understanding of this local community
and when she went back to architecture
school was able to create a knowledge
transfer between her as the designer but
also as someone who understood the
community to create a building that
emerges from the place as opposed to
being given to the place so a kind of
different role or relationship between
the architect and then in terms of
sustainability they used all local
materials loan which is kind of straw
and clay beaten up by water buffalos and
bamboo using these kind of three these
layered bamboo with joined together to
really create a new school and in a way
the kind of for me the solutions point
to in effect ways that in-depth
knowledge of the local condition can
actually maybe be a model for how we
think about sustainability both in our
backyard or further away so this
experience got me to thinking about it
and mapping and so what happens is the
auger con awards are 30 years old they
take place every three years and what I
did is I mapped the last three cycles
locating the place of all the winning
projects so this is 2001
2004 and then the most recent one is
2007 you can see their geography being
of a certain belt that encompasses the
Muslim world and is fairly predictable
of a certain climate and the same time
in 1993 I was fortunate to receive a
canada council grant and that enabled me
to travel to scandinavia and so Howard
and I spent eight weeks traveling
through Norway Denmark Sweden Finland
and we were also invited to the tenth
alto symposium which took place in
you've asked Allah and in a way a kind
of understanding for me of modernity
intertwined with a kind of egalitarian
society and nation building was
something that i could only maybe
understand from actually being there and
seeing these sort of communal gatherings
so what it is I mapped the speakers of
the last three Altos symposiums because
it again is 30 years old it takes place
every three years and in a way in each
of the three cycles so here is 2003 this
was probably Glen market down here I
think 2006 and then what I think is
really interesting for me is 2009
because what started to happen was two
of the winners of the agua con award
Francisca day from Burkina Faso and Anna
henninger who designed the bamboo school
were both speakers along with speakers
from Thailand India and South Africa and
for me it signals a kind of different
conversation that before it was a
northern conversation with a few people
from the the British Empire with a kind
of other discussion happening
Muslim world and I think that what's
really interesting is to start to
imagine it actually being part of the
same conversation these kind of
alternate models for practice and what I
wanted to do is to quote so here you're
seeing the two combined you're actually
seeing the kind of new merging of this
kind of different map of the world where
the conversation between the high
architecture quote and the kind of these
other projects are maybe part of the
same discussion and I wanted to quote
from an article that Billy TN wrote as
part of the last publication for the
yogic on and she spoke about in talking
about the impact of this award she said
the connection of the award to the
larger architectural world is crucial
because it speaks of the marriage of
high design with ethics too often good
intentions are realized in the form of
mediocre architecture there's a general
attitude that says that it doesn't have
to be so good if it's for a good cause
we must demand that good intentions are
expressed by the highest level of design
in this way the quality of the
aspiration can be matched by the quality
of the built work I guess for me every
student in this room has the capacity to
shape and transform the world around
them in profound ways and I think
everyone here is very privileged to be
part of a kind of institution that is at
the leading edge of architecture let's
begin by knowing as Jane Jacobs would
say your own backyard let's share the
lessons that we've learned with others
and let's build buildings that touch and
shapes people's lives in meaningful ways
that also demonstrate the profound
benefits of exemplary architecture thank
you very much
thank you for loving talk which is not a
way that we work with a high-minded good
thoughts for all of us as we begin a new
year so especially wonderful I can't ask
for questions if you take a few
questions totally happy to have a little
bit of time yep tradition to ask the
speakers to respond to questions from
the audience are there any questions but
this is one up on the balcony
I thank you you spoke convincingly of
the value to architecture of knowing
your own backyard it seems that we tend
to think of architectural education as
more of an international thing students
we gather from around the world when we
do studio projects around the world and
then we disperse again is that as it
should be in your opinion um I think
that's a very good question you know as
someone who didn't go to an Ivy League
school and went to a public school in
Canada because all the architecture
schools are public I'm always struck by
the challenge of students in
institutions that have a really high
tuition and I think that I'm I well
partly the part of it is that the
studios you take our kind of you know
out there and you're challenging they're
challenging and really exciting and then
the kind of difficulty is that when you
have a really high debt load when you
graduate especially in a discipline like
architecture it's actually harder to
take risks it's harder to kind of do
something that is you know like some of
these projects are kind of like out
there projects because when they start
they didn't know if it would be a
project how am I going to raise the
money what they're there so it's it's
it's a really interesting question and I
think it's the relationship between the
amazing opportunities of your education
and the range of things that you're
exposed to in a school context and then
the kind of need to pay back your debt
and how do you survive it's a it's a
challenging contradiction and it's hard
to it's a it's a tough one and people
have different ways of resolving it but
i would say for you know when i went to
school we could take risks when we
graduated because we didn't actually
have the kind of burden and it meant you
could live more like a student for
long time and experiment with a bunch of
project and see them built and figure
out what was going on and it's a it's a
it's I think sometimes harder when
you're kind of maybe more you're exposed
to more and you're in the spotlight more
and then you you've got a kind of you
don't have as much time to make some
mistakes or to learn a bit slower it's a
it's a tricky thing so I don't know if
I've answered your question but I think
it raises a lot of important issues that
you each have to grapple with in your
own way other questions yeah I have a
question about the last point you made
in terms of high design marrying high
design with ethics and the the point you
made was that you want to match the
quality of the aspiration with the
quality of good work which i think is a
really critical question and as a
landscape architect ecologists in
oftentimes the criteria or the issues
that I'm thinking about from an
ecological standpoint might take
priority over some of the design issues
and vice versa and I'm wondering when
you start thinking about that interplay
of a kind of ethical agenda with
architectural goals do you do you think
that you can achieve the kind of
architectural dialogue and issues that
have been around for the last 50 years
in terms of form an aesthetic
materiality or are those shifting and
starting to evolve into other another
set of kind of architectural agendas and
I asked that partly because in a way
part of your discussion was about
mapping and mapping at different scales
and looking for hidden elements of you
know of your sites so which starts to
suggest it to me that maybe by revealing
hidden elements you're starting to
relate or expose aesthetic values that
may not have been there in the past and
so I'm just curious can you sort of
describe from the architecture today how
this interplay is taking place in
whether it's
the traditional architecture or as
architecture is shifting into new arenas
in terms of its in terms of what it is
you're trying to match and what the
agendas are within it does that I don't
know if that makes sense yeah no I think
I think you've kind of captured some of
the unset aspects of the talk and I
think that was interesting today in the
option studio lotteries where you know
Diana and Joel and Alessandro there are
many of these questions about kind of
the environmental component of our
buildings in relation to kind of design
and I think that that my premise is that
they're not mutually exclusive there
they are intertwined but sometimes they
take longer or they don't fall into the
more traditional professional way of
realizing architecture or clients have
to have a different timeline or
something's got to adjust in the
equation to actually get both to happen
at the same time and I think that we
need to as architects maybe sometimes
push back or design or create these
alternate models to actually allow these
things not to be mutually exclusive but
to be embedded into the same project but
you can't do it when you're you know on
a kind of blasting timeline or kind of
you know there are other factors that
drive the kind of the reasons for
architecture being a certain way and we
need to there needs to be some
give-and-take in that equation to
actually have these mutual agendas
coexist and be synthesized in a project
so so I think that we have to be
designing the process for those kinds of
projects to emerge as opposed to you
know expecting them to happen I think
there also is a class of much more
educated clients who also believe
passionately in kind of issues of
sustainability and ecology and I think
that they will also help to create these
new buildings architects can't do them
on their own
I know you think a lot in her very
involved with the City of Toronto
because I've come up and visit you I've
been lucky enough to go through a number
of your projects to the work you said
today you didn't actually show the the
park project which I surprise which to
me is the real civic project and most of
the houses are single single occupant
sometimes you're single owners and
inward turn when they're in the city and
everybody they turn inward in the city
and turn outward at nature and I'm
curious where your practice is at now
given the extraordinary things that
you've done whether projects of larger
scale that are reflective of the
pressures in toronto right now which
you're involved in would be of interest
of you or whether you are choosing at
this point your career to stay in this
zone of work that you've you've been
doing for the last 10 15 years yeah take
on a tall building or some of the things
i didn't did you did everyone hear the
question yeah okay I think we're
actually doing probably the biggest
project we've ever done which is a
private hospital assisted living and a
chapel for a group of Catholic nuns and
it's a Russell really large project in
scale it's actually on the other side of
the ravine from the integral house so
you can actually see one from the other
so it's this kind of ravine site it
actually has a it'll probably be the
greenest building of its type in Toronto
when it's done with geothermal solar hot
water preheat cross ventilation and
we've been working with them for about
four years so it's very complicated
municipal approval process so in a way
it will be interesting to see how it
turns out and two because in a way we've
embedded a lot of the ethical issues
with the client who actually wants a
building that when they're no longer
living will speak to who they are so it
has a kind of fairly heavy component to
it and and I think that what we did at
the beginning of that process was we
actually had seminars for that we
created seminars where we had all the
experts and sustainability come and talk
to
we educated them about what the issues
are so they could be in effect an
educated client in the process and I
think that for us that was a way of in
effect us thinking about how to design
the process to actually achieve the
right results that had in it you know
the different issues that we're trying
to intertwine so it's a and I think that
we are really interested in different
scales of buildings and we just take a
bit longer than most people to get there
just like it's we're not fast we're slow
but you know it's just how we work